Panzer Hunter has returned with a series
of brand new manga chapters after being
on Hiatus for
1423 days that's almost four years
without a chapter but after many fans
had already given up on ever seeing the
continuation of this fantastic and
unique story hisoka and Co finally are
having their big comeback however you
might not be aware of the Bittersweet
story behind the long Hiatus how close
Hunter Hansa actually came to being done
for good and how in the end yoshihiro
Togashi overcame the massive op stacked
against him and his story to actually
make it to publication one more time
it's a story of Pain sickness the curse
of being a genius writer and of a man
who has dedicated his everything to his
work and his fans and while it's already
clear that this new material is
seamlessly picking up with the high
quality left off on after such a long
time it's easy to lose track of what's
actually going on right now in the story
see what characters are important and
what you can expect of the upcoming
chapters and the overall future of the
story so this is everything you need to
know about the long-awaited return of
Hunter Hunter there aren't really too
many stories that can allow themselves
to suddenly go on an unannounced and
open-ended Hiatus and then come back
four years later to an euphoric fan base
that is more excited and hungry for new
stories than maybe ever before that
alone should already give you a taste of
just how special hanza Hansa truly is as
a story after years of complete silence
since its last chapter in weekly Shonen
Jump magazine on November 26 2018 with
no one knowing what the status of the
story really was and why there had been
no news for such a long time author
yoshihiro Togashi finally appeared out
of nowhere on a brand new Twitter
profile on May 24th 2022 with the
following tweets
four more chapters left for now Togashi
must have expected all kinds of
reactions to the suite maybe no one
would notice it maybe people would be
angry with him for practically ghosting
his entire fan base for four years or
even worse maybe people had just stopped
caring for his story altogether and
moved on instead what happened next is
something that neither he nor anyone
else probably could have ever imagined
the entire internet exploded and I
really mean that I've never seen
anything like it happen before the most
unlikely assortment of people you could
ever imagine came together under this
tweet to celebrate the corner of a manga
page with a little sketch that looked
like someone had just played around with
his pen and forgotten to put the cap
back on from massive YouTubers like Mr
Beast to the most random assortment of
Brands like KFC or X body spray everyone
was excited seemingly about the prospect
of this man's scribbles tagashi's
Twitter account blasted itself to 2
million followers in a few days and now
stands at 3 million only a few months
after its launch where he has been
publishing updates on his progress that
must have been a massive relief and
probably somewhat overwhelming to him to
see all these positive responses he got
but what to an outsider must have looked
like millions of people going absolutely
nuts about a few Doodles on badly lit
paper has a very easy explanation Hunter
Hunter is a one-of-a-kind story even in
the world of Shonen that at the peak
level pretty much consists of nothing
but high quality Stories the secret
recipe well Togashi took a close look at
mainstream Shonen and decided to flip it
completely on its head as a concept
pioneering a whole sub-genre of
successful series like Attack on Titan
due to kaisen or chainsaw man he
basically looked at the established
format of major stories like Dragon Ball
one piece of Naruto and wondered what
would happen if he treated these stories
realistically the result is that Hunter
starts out pretty much like a normal
Shonen but its main character gone
freaks goes from cheerfully powerful
good boy to one of the darkest and most
disillusioned characters in modern
fiction the entire story very quickly
becomes very dark and very morally
complex turns out that a 13 year old boy
who thinks they're only good and bad
people will have a hard time in the real
world that's filled with morally
ambiguous characters the story in its
World feel incredibly real and
refreshing as the intricate politics and
challenges of the world shape its Heroes
and not the other way around togashi's
character writing is some of the best if
not the best in all of manga each
character with Incredible depth and
moral complexity garnish this with a
fantastic power system like nen and you
have a story that is beloved by millions
of people and yet we almost never got
this continuation of hunter hunter in
the first place yoshiro Togashi began
his work in Hansa Hansa on March 16th 98
and has produced 36 volumes with 390s
chapters in it which sounds like a lot
until you compare it with a story like
one piece that released just one year
prior and has published over 1 000
chapters until today almost three times
as many the reason for this has been the
increasing amount of weeks that Togashi
took off from publishing the story when
you look at the hanza Hansa Hiatus chart
which yes is a real thing then you can
see how the manga starts out with a lot
of blue weeks where the manga was
actually published continually growing
redder and redder until around 2006
where it switches into long streaks of
red and blue kind of alternating what
the story would go on a break for a
while and then publish around 10
chapters in a row and then these
stretches of red that it takes to
produce a handful of chapters get longer
and longer until 2018 where we finally
hit that big red wall that is the
four-year Hiatus we're just coming out
of right now what in the world is going
on here well it turns out that yoshiro
despite being incredibly passionate and
caring about his work as a mangaka has
been fighting with terrible health
problems ever since starting the story
that have made it almost impossible for
him to continue his work these problems
included increasingly excruciating back
and chest pain that made it very hard
for him to move and draw on top of that
he then also started to sleep poorly
which soon turned into full-blown
insomnia in parts of course due to his
chronic pain that kept his body from
getting the necessary rest it really
needed to heal as a result he ultimately
became bedridden and pretty much
incapable of working on the story for
weeks and sometimes months on ends
Togashi eventually decided to share this
terrible and exhausting cycle with his
fans in a series of author notes
appearing alongside a few chapters that
he still managed to release at the time
now we don't really know for sure but
it's very likely that his four year
absence also was caused by his declining
Health as he tried to focus on recovery
some people speculated during that time
that but maybe it wasn't his health
after all maybe tagashi had simply
written himself into a corner with the
story and was just kind of looking to
get out of that after writing a pretty
much perfect ending to The Adventures of
gone in kilua he shifted his Focus to
setting up the dark continents a place
that has been hyped up with such high
expectations that some would argue it
was impossible to properly deliver on
and while I personally think that that
definitely was part of his struggle at
that time Togashi has proven often
enough just how capable of a writer he
truly is that wouldn't shy away from
that type of challenge I think and
indeed with his return to the public
world through Twitter and sharing his
progress on the recent chapters fans
were very optimistic not only that they
would finally get to see the dark
continents but also that his condition
must have been somewhat improving some
even going so far as speculating that a
continuous weekly release would be
possible again from now on however this
couldn't have been any further from the
truth in July Togashi admitted that he
was even unable to sit upright and that
he was now drawing the line art for his
remaining chapters while lying down then
until August his health once again
seemed to steadily decline tweeting that
he had only finished a single panel not
having enough strength to keep even the
grip on his pen in that moment the
entire project seemed to be at risk of
ending bright then and there however at
that point also something changed
whether it was his own will to keep
writing a story and keep his promise to
his audience or it was his overall
health slowly improving slightly or
maybe even a mix of both in the end
Togashi decided to not give up and keep
fighting he worked hard and was
determined to finish the 10 chapters for
release which has now finally happened
and which he must have been incredibly
proud of so with that out of the way
what exactly is going on right now in
the manga and where are we going from
here well if you only watch the anime or
simply need a quick refresher here is a
quick overview over what happened
between the chairman selection Arc and
the new chapters releasing right now
with gone having no more nen and kilua
on a wholesome Journey with his little
sister the focus of the story has now
completely shifted to Kurapika who is
the main character now as well as liorio
to some degree both of them have now
joined the zodiacs the top 12 Hunters
which has started the ninth Arc of
Hunter Hunter known as the succession
War Arc now this may sound weird but
right now everything takes place on a
giant boat that's shaped like a big
black whale that is slowly traveling
towards a Dark Continent a place that is
mostly undiscovered and that is filled
with powerful nen creatures such as for
example the Chimera and queen and on
this ship there is now this battle
royale happening between 14 princes of
the kakin Kingdom for who's going to get
to be king each of them having an envisa
disposal for the fight though the rules
really get quite complicated The Zodiacs
of the hunter Association are on board
to escort Isaac nitero's son on his
expedition to the dark continents
Kurapika is their to retrieve the last
of his Clans missing Scarlet eyes from
the fourth Prince and probably main
antagonist of this Arc said ignish the
Phantom troop is also there looking for
hisoka who after a death match with
crolo that he had wanted for a long time
had killed two of The Troop Members Plus
there is the struggle amongst the number
of mafia families all on that boat so
you tell me if that sounds interesting
or not it seems that for now we'll be
getting a minimum of 10 chapters and
then we can really only hope that
togashi's health stabilizes so we will
see a continuation of the story after
that hopefully with less than four years
of waiting the new material will
continue this fantastic Journey towards
the Dark Continent and will give us the
return of some of our most beloved
characters like crowlo hisoka and
Kurapika while also introducing a ton of
new fascinating characters on top if you
want to know for example what makes
hisoka such a fantastic character well
you can just watch my analysis of him
here next